practiquemos un poco más a dibujar
proyecciones de newman nuestro objetivo
es observar el enlace entre el carbono 2
y el carbono 3 en este compuesto en el
inciso a
nuestro objetivo es dibujar la
conformación más estable entonces
empecemos por numerar nuestros carbonos
digamos que este carbono es el carbono 1
carbono 2 carbono 3 y carbono 4 nos
piden observar la molécula desde el
enlace c2 c3 este enlace así que
necesitamos observar la molécula desde
esta perspectiva nuestro objetivo es
encontrar la conformación más estable y
sabemos por los vídeos anteriores que es
la conformación alternada entonces vamos
a dibujar una conformación alternada y a
partir de esa dibujamos las demás para
después elegir la que sea más
en energía es decir la más estable aquí
tenemos el carbono 1 y el carbono 2 con
un hidrógeno hacia nosotros y un grupo
metilo lejos de nosotros unido al
carbono 3 tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
nosotros y un nitrógeno lejos de
nosotros y después tenemos el carbono 4
necesitamos observar el enlace entre el
carbono 2 y 3 para dibujar la proyección
de newman aquí podemos ver la proyección
de newman en la conformación alternada y
para obtener otra conformación rotamos
el carbono de adelante sin mover el
carbono de atrás así obtenemos otra
conformación alternada y si rotamos
nuevamente nos queda otra posible
conformación alternada
en el vídeo observamos la molécula desde
el enlace entre el carbono 2 y 3 es
decir desde esta perspectiva y buscamos
las posibles con formaciones alternadas
para este compuesto ahora es importante
que podamos dibujar las proyecciones de
newman sin usar un modelo molecular
entonces si observamos el carbono 2 que
sería este carbono en nuestra proyección
de newman lo vamos a representar con un
punto y después tenemos un hidrógeno que
va hacia arriba y hacia la derecha si
nuestros ojos están justo aquí
observamos que el hidrógeno está hacia
la derecha y hacia arriba entonces
tenemos un hidrógeno por aquí después
tenemos un grupo metilo que está hacia
arriba y hacia la izquierda
entonces tenemos un ch 3 arriba y hacia
la izquierda y también tenemos un grupo
metilo hacia abajo ch 3 hacia abajo
ahora para el carbono 3 que corresponde
a este carbono no podemos verlo desde
esta perspectiva porque nos tapa el
carbono 2 pero en la proyección de
newman podemos representarlo con un
círculo entonces este círculo representa
al carbono 3 y que tenemos en el carbono
3 bueno tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
arriba ahí está también tenemos un ch 3
hacia abajo y hacia la derecha entonces
ch 3 y luego tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
abajo y hacia la izquierda
esta es nuestra primera proyección de
newman si rotamos el carbono frontal sin
mover el carbono de atrás obtenemos otra
conformación alternada entonces tomamos
este grupo metilo y lo rotamos hasta
esta posición así que a este hidrógeno
lo movimos hasta aquí y este grupo
metilo lo rotamos a esta posición
entonces primero dibujemos el carbono de
atrás que permanece igual
tenemos este grupo ch3
y otros de h3 también tenemos a este
hidrógeno
recuerden solo rotamos el carbono
frontal
aquí tenemos nuestros dedos y rotamos el
grupo metilo rosa hacia acá después
movimos el hidrógeno en azul hacia acá y
finalmente movimos este grupo metilo en
verde a esta posición justo aquí
esta es otra conformación alternada
ahora para la última conformación
tomamos este grupo metilo rosa y lo
rotamos hasta acá con lo que el
hidrógeno azul se movió a esta posición
y el grupo metilo verde se movió hacia
aquí como el carbono de atrás permanece
igual vamos a redibujar lo tenemos
nuestro círculo
un ch 3 aquí por acá otro ch 3 y
finalmente un hidrógeno ahora el grupo
metilo en rosa ha quedado hacia abajo
ahí está el hidrógeno se movió a esta
posición y el grupo metilo verde quedó
aquí
estas son nuestras con formaciones
alternadas pero vamos a compararlas con
las conformaciones que vimos en el vídeo
observen que coinciden con lo que hemos
dibujado cuál será la conformación más
estable bueno sabemos que cuando tenemos
un grupo metilo muy cerca de otro metilo
hay repulsión se le conoce como
interacción coach en el vídeo sobre
análisis con formación al del butano
vimos que una interacción coach tiene
3.8 kilos por mol de energía kilo jules
por mol y tenemos otra interacción goes
por aquí y otra por acá entonces como
tenemos tres interacciones coach eso nos
da una energía total de 11.4 kilos por
mol 3.8 por 3 ahora analicemos esta
conformación aquí tenemos una
interacción goals
aquí tenemos otra y otra
nuevamente tenemos tres interacciones
goals entonces la energía total también
es de 11.4 kilo jules por mol
y qué me dicen de la primera
conformación aquí tenemos una
interacción goes y aquí tenemos otra
sólo tenemos dos interacciones así que
la energía total es de 7.6 kilos urss
por mol
esta es la energía más baja entonces es
la conformación más estable
el inciso b nos pide que dibujemos la
conformación menos estable es decir de
energía más alta entonces veamos el
vídeo del modelo molecular pasaremos de
la conformación alternada a la eclipsada
y luego buscaremos las posibles con
formaciones eclipsadas una de ellas será
la menos estable aquí tenemos la
conformación alternada si la rotamos
obtenemos la conformación eclipsada si
rotamos de nuevo obtenemos otra
conformación eclipsada y si la volteo
podemos ver que los grupos metilo están
muy cerca ese impedimento estético
desestabiliza la conformación si
regresamos a la conformación eclipsada y
la rotamos obtenemos la última
conformación eclipsada para este
compuesto
aquí tenemos las fotografías de las
conformaciones eclipsadas dibujemos la
proyección de newman para cada una
empecemos con esta conformación aquí
tenemos nuestros setos que es el carbono
frontal y se representa con un punto
después tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
arriba que lo pondré un poco chueco para
que podamos ver lo que ocurre atrás
después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
y hacia la derecha ahí está y por acá
tenemos otro grupo metilo tenemos un ch
3 del lado izquierdo
ahora el carbono de atrás lo
representamos con un círculo
y que está unido a nuestro carbono 3
bueno aquí tenemos un grupo metilo
entonces tenemos un metilo por aquí y
después tenemos otro metilo por acá ch 3
y tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
esta es la proyección de newman para
esta conformación eclipsada
vamos con la siguiente este es nuestros
dedos nuestro punto y luego tenemos un
grupo metilo hacia arriba y hacia la
derecha aquí tenemos un ch 3 y por acá
tenemos un ch 3
después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
y hacia la izquierda
ahora como el carbono de atrás permanece
igual aquí tenemos un grupo metilo ch3
también tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
abajo y hacia la derecha y después
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia la izquierda
justo aquí esta es la proyección de
newman para esta conformación y lo que
hicimos fue rotar el carbono frontal si
tomamos este grupo metilo y lo rotamos
el grupo metilo rosa nos queda en esta
posición con lo que el hidrógeno azul
roto a esta posición corresponde a este
hidrógeno y finalmente este grupo metilo
verde roto a esta posición que
corresponde a este ahora veamos nuestra
última conformación eclipsada
este es nuestro set 2 carbono frontal
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia arriba y
hacia la derecha también tenemos un
grupo metilo hacia abajo
ch 3 y luego tenemos un grupo metilo
hacia acá
ch 3 dibujemos el carbono de atrás
este es el carbono 3 que permanece igual
así que tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
arriba otro metilo hacia acá que
corresponde a este y finalmente un
hidrógeno por aquí y lo que hicimos para
obtener esta conformación fue mover este
grupo metilo rosa hacia acá que ahora
corresponde a este ese h 3 el hidrógeno
azul roto a esta posición que ahora
corresponde a este hidrógeno y
finalmente rotamos el grupo metilo verde
hasta esta posición estas son nuestras
con formaciones eclipsadas
identifiquemos la más alta en energía
empecemos con esta proyección de newman
aquí tenemos un grupo metilo eclipsado
con un hidro g
sabemos que esto tiene una energía de 6
kilos por mol después tenemos la misma
situación por aquí 6 kilos por mol y
finalmente tenemos un grupo metilo
eclipsado con otro metilo entonces esta
energía es de 11 kilos jules por mol
en total tenemos una energía de 23 kilos
jules por mol 23 kilos urss por mol para
esta conformación eclipsada ahora
analicemos esta observen que ocurre lo
mismo tenemos un grupo metilo eclipsado
con un hidrógeno su energía es 6 por acá
tenemos la misma situación así que
también es 6 y luego tenemos un grupo
metilo eclipsado con otro metilo esto es
11 así que en total
también tenemos 23 kilos jules formol
para
esta conformación finalmente analicemos
esta observen que es un poco diferente
aquí tenemos un par de hidrógenos que
están eclipsados tienen una energía de
cuatro kilos urss por mol después
tenemos un grupo metilo eclipsado con
otro metilo tienen una energía de 11
kilos por mol y luego tenemos otro par
de metilo eclipsados entonces tenemos
otros 11 kilos urss por mol 11 más 11
más 4 esto es igual a 26 kilos jules por
mol
esta es la conformación más alta en
energía y por lo tanto es la menos
estable debido a que los grupos metilo
están más cerca entre ellos y como son
voluminosos eso desestabiliza la
conformación recuerden que siempre
buscamos alejar a los grupos voluminosos
lo más
que se pueda